271 lead on the net's seventh and final  game of this  eastern conference semifinal series  here's middleton off the screen oh look  out  as durant was hit hard by p.j  tucker as durant was leaping for that  rebound  and that is four fouls on pj tucker  which  obviously something to keep an eye on  but as they're going for the ball right  there  tucker ran right in to durant and  collided the second  collision that durant's had here in this  third quarter  more importantly for tucker that's four  fouls as i said his  match-up with durant so important  defensively for the bucks  and the bucks now over the foul of it  kevin durant three of four at the line  that's point number 28. and it looked  like right there  kevin durant's mom talking with pj  tucker  that's wanda sitting courtside  and can't read lips because the mask is  on  i'm sure it was all friendly really  well they they're friends they get alone  pj  claims he does tj tucker hosted  kevin durant on his recruiting trip